primo vincolata ciao a tutti il mio
penale einstein oggi aveva fare un
figlio al fresco con la nuova e andiamo
subito a vedere cosa parlate capito che
la vita è davvero di spielberg azioniste
pensata la mia voce
allora questi siamo due topolini e
topolino non capolino poi il topolino
allora nuova challenge la ruota delle
sorprese e delle schifezze no anche però
chi sono penitente schifezze cose buone
e sorprese per altri primo tireremo la
ruota uno alla volta e quello che ci
capita dovremmo o scartarlo o farlo o
mangiarlo tu ami e che cosa picchiati ma
io vedo una cosa che però mi piace tanto
e qual è anche vero che la bp l'aglio in
pratica vitale come un super golosone ha
accettato di fare questa challenge solo
perché voi in mezzo esistono cioccolato
settembre quindi lui spera solo che
diciamo sempre scorso ho fatto il tifo
per me e facciamo in modo che avvitare
capri tinaio est e le cose cattive
romano tutto per sempre cose tipo o per
me o per di tale cinque turni a testa
alternati miracolose motivo per me
in più delle cose da scartare come altre
tre gol fashion cast erano mai aperte
per poter scartare ma se capitano al
tempo del proprio vedere come le scarpe
perché una nuova cosa che non so nemmeno
come si apre che in trio della loro
classe pensati per la meeting invece è
una penitenza
cos'è che saprete insomma lo slam
bisogna infilare una mano dentro lo
slide mostrate capita a 7 in realtà
perché bello grande così fosse veramente
in belgio stilò mano destra
purtroppo spero di non rimanere
incollata perché me lo metto qua
pacatissimo quindi si sciolgono reagan è
proprio una penitenza a infilare la mano
dentro uno slide allora 400 carissimo
quindi sicuramente diventato un po che
ci costo in più in piena della valle
intera
praticamente quasi anche il braccio
potrebbe rimanere incastrati
quindi vediamo un po senti che sony smr
però poi non perdona nello per sempre
ok ora devo provare a tirare fuori la
mano è vincolata addio nonno o almeno
con una mano è impossibile liberarsi
proviamo con due mani
oddio anche attaccando meno male numero
ma non è rimasto che tra un po pizzi
cosey fanni nell'appartamento ma che
tocca ambientale speriamo bene grande
corte ha neanche questa parola arte non
ti mangi tu ce la prendiamo in un tipo
schivo che ti capita capita per primo
podio l'aglio dai nomi no no no no stai
come si fa nulla se va bene possono così
a rio bo lo sta sbocciando sempre di più
la roma
[Applauso]
non fate schifo l'aglio macro nudo c'era
anche un ego 8 proprio desktop e ammette
che puzza ma fa tanto schifo ma poi fa
schifo laglio con o perché l'approccio è
successa vuoto ma dai
mastica pratica basic e allora c'è un
odore di aguero detto preziosi
tocca a me è ormai un cambio possa
offrire la mia sorpresa lost prophets 6
e 4 ecco qua la loro spetta io spero
sempre di trovare o un gatto o un
cavallino ma anche un
o bagaglino mi piacerebbe tanto perché
sono gli animali compilazione di più
quindi apriamo la e provate a indovinare
chi animale troverò dentro
vediamo chi indovina cielo quasi
riuscita con distruggendo si celando
come una cipolla metallo il nostro
indizio
prima dobbiamo trovare la nostra mente
allora la folle rosa quindi non è una
gara odio queste cerniere radio ce l'ha
fatta
ok affermo l'apollo finalmente vediamo
un po permanente che iniziasse allora
abbiamo una lampadina e dei pantaloni
cosa vorrà dire speriamo che la prima
mattina
c'è un biberon abbiamo qua una palettina
con il cuoricino
non so cosa voglia dire che animale può
essere con il cuoricino non ho mai visto
la palettina come pulcino qua abbiamo
degli occhialoni stile harry potter
chi è il nostro pezzo è un uccellino
non capisco è un pezzo forte andiamo a
vedere nel foglietto che chiarire ai
capelli rosa è strano vedere qui c'è
capelli rosa con le colline e ti cerco
quindi fa parte della spirit club ed è
un cubetto e neanche questa volta
purtroppo nessun gatto nessun cavallino
ma magari mi capiterà la prossima volta
vediamo come sta quegli occhiali perché
andiamo avanti con la salle e vediamo un
po
[Musica]
alla vita e super doloso broi torna sono
gli piacciono 8 non capisco il perchè
però scommetto che se contento l'affare
è fatto ecco qua il nastro da neanche
non mi piace non vuol dire anche un
romanzo sembra buono ma da terzo round
[Musica]
no no perché sono fortunate questo
possiamo pure dell'alga oppure
nuovamente la mano e lo slime i due
bimbi che bello perché capita al
cartello per poter vedere come lo fai
l'onu passion prize
non ho idea di come si apra proviamo
insieme perché quale ce lo faccia molta
pressione e meglio vediamo o incredibile
ascesa pure io riuscivo ad aprirlo
vediamo se ti capita vediamo vediamo un
po cosa c'è che in questo primo strato a
c'è il foglietto e mi dice tutte le cose
che possono capitare mi che sono tutti
gli outfit che carini mi piace un sacco
questo sotto roso questo tutto nero o
questo glitterato vediamo quale mi
capita all altra cerniera è in diagonale
tv
ok ce l'ho fatta sono lenti anche qua
cosa bisognerà guardare comunque capito
e ci sono dei cappelli disegnati ecco
qua questa è la cosa più interessante
infatti avevo letto che praticamente
questi vestitini stanno dentro uno slime
vediamo un po duro però devo dire
gelatinoso oddio come la certo un hummer
da in pratica è uno slime duro però ben
dentro ha investiti incastrati oddio
porta una scarpina poi vediamo che cosa
stranissima che era fuori la cosa da
questa specie di spline indurito c'è una
magliettina rosa molto carina anche
questo però è piena di gene anche dentro
nella manica un pò strane insomma queste
cose poi dice stranissimo non so se c'è
altro che mi sono persa ai quali sono le
mutande lo stesso piene di gel ha dentro
il reboot en danger una scarpa
ecco l'altra scarpa con la montagna
quindi questo è l'auspicio completo e
quale scarpe col gel dentro unboxing
completato e farà un per vitale vediamo
[Musica]
peccato che non l'hai fatto per primo la
bozza che voglio proprio vedere come
mettere dentro l'inghilterra alla
cerniera che facciamo la cerniera molto
più facile le più facili che abbiamo
aiuti ancora perche avverte che vuol
dire questa cerniera di quel mai allora
vediamo la lente nessuno studioso di
guardare tutto con la lente e condanno
questo mondo libero e quindi marebbe che
forse bisogna fare così e poi come
diceva di toglierla e poi preso una
calma
sulla carta avevo visto che poi bisogna
tipo fare anche un budino trema perché a
sensazione strana di pietro addio stai
appreso vediamo cos'è questo che cosa si
fa questi dobbiamo i pantaloni sono 6 k
a me no mutando la mutanda una scarpa
gialla mutandari l'appoggiava se questo
nuovo che cos'è tonello scarpanti dalle
tute no un altro un altro pezzo mosca
approccio né dell'altra scampati
sappiamo il top che è aperta con le
stelline bianca
non c'è il piano altresì la scarpa da
trasporto all'altro top della stampa ma
è vedere è un santo no no no come
stilista il bracciale ma vanno
accelerati da uno scalda carta polpacci
ok of boxing completato questa cosa però
fa molto strano
quarto round che alla fine fortunata
tournée visite il cioccolato che voleva
vita altri addirittura giusta marijuana
donne so proprio che la sta invece visto
ben naso in freezer è buonissimo
[Musica]
riesce ma è capito allora bacio slime
allora venite turno beh allora ho scelto
io questo slime per te perché non e
appiccicoso e rimasto abbastanza duro e
crouch ai temi che ti rimane tutto un
pizzino
passino si mangia no vaccino video e bay
ma puzza di schiuma da barba
ebbene tutto lamenti della da barbara
schiuma da barba fatta non solo dai noi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
come votando un ricordo bellissimo
[Musica]
buona serata è un po profumo ultim'ora
un quinto round tocca beh mi è uscito
uno stop
nell'ultimo round quindi donato va bene
perché comunque mi è andata proprio bene
permette possibile tocca l'ultimo round
è così che le paste al limone
però però se schifoso delle cose alcune
invece niente solo la giambellino
azzerato dai vediamo
[Musica]
speriamo bene il timo e limone e limone
questo oppure deraglio ma poteva
capitare di questo poi questi quasi
guardo lo preferisco ne è capitata la
sun bello buono e lo sto quindi devi
essere contento che quando stati posti
capitato considero di scrittore
dopo il bacino quello slime ci vuole
fuori limone fatemi sapere se anche voi
avete sali noto anche se non sentite lo
dovrei vedete il limone di carlo sì
perchè lui non può alla fine
porro de lotto incredibile guarda poi
ricordati mangeresti colpo di aglio
allora ragazzi se volete che rifacciamo
questa challenge mettendo nuove sorprese
nuove corre da soli un bel laiche a
10.000 la ex tremo fare la seconda parte
andremo a farne un'altra ma senza
l'aglio e la cipolla l'aglio vero
leggero quindi lasciate uguale su questo
video ne parlate caduti facciamo
infiniti si pone nei commenti in cosa
includere come la ruota e ora vi
lasciamo 4 gazebi nesquik cliccare per
vedere le nostre altre sale tm live
quella che preferite e buona visione
[Musica]